hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in fear and trembling and indeed in many
of his other works soon Kierkegaard is
going to talk about faith as a passion
and this may put off a lot of readers at
the very beginning because they have a
different conception of faith where it's
something much more about propositions
that one a sense to having faith and not
having knowledge in certain things being
the case they may also be a bit put off
as philosophers because there tends to
be a considerable distrust of wresting
anything on the basis of the passions or
emotions or drives or anything affective
on the part of philosophical discussion
exposition argument why because it's
felt that that's far too subjective that
if I don't have the same feeling or
emotion or desire I won't be able to
relate to it it won't be universally
valid and objective and and Kierkegaard
can say yes there is that aspect over
here but what I'm concerned with over
here requires that I think of things in
terms of the passions and in terms of
faith as the highest passion of a human
being at one point in the work
Kierkegaard does say that when it comes
to for example arguments for the
existence of God or how we ought to live
we really cannot do without some sort of
we might call it passional basis that if
we want to have any sort of genuine
conviction we do need the passions so
faith as Kierkegaard is describing it is
besides being a comportment besides
being an idea besides being all sorts of
other things it is a passion so we ought
to think first about well what is a
passion so often used as a sort of
synonym for emotion or feeling and there
is a wide range some authors like to
make a distinction between different
kinds of emotional or affective states
that would have passions on one side and
feelings on another maybe moods over
here but Kierkegaard is not doing that
so much although we're going to see him
distinguishing faith from other emotions
or passions but a passion is some sort
of emotional state does that mean that
it's purely emotion that it doesn't
involve any cognition that it doesn't
have any cognitive or propositional or
judgment aspects to it that's not the
case and faith is a prime example of
this the person who actually has faith
or lives within it is going to believe
all sorts of things and act on the basis
of those beliefs it is going to carry
out some reasoning processes that are
informed by or oriented or even
encouraged you might say and sustained
by that very emotion of faith and
orientation is another thing that we can
talk about what it means to have faith
is to be oriented towards some things
and away from others and to be oriented
towards something higher than oneself
that in some way one relates to or
participates in so that's another
important idea faith also involves some
sort of action comportment there's that
old you know phrase coming from one of
the the letters that you know faith
without works is dead and indeed
although Kierkegaard is a Lutheran and
and you know there's that whole
justification by faith thing Kierkegaard
thinks that works in fact matter that if
you do have faith you're going to do
things it's going to express itself in
that way and we might also think about
responses as well not just action but
taking things on and some people could
talk about passion as drive when we say
follow your passion right if Kierkegaard
is right following the passion of faith
would in fact be quite good for you not
every passion is something that you
should follow if your passion is of
doing something terrible because you
know your passion is say infinite
revenge on humanity for having brought
you into this world maybe don't follow
that passion with this passion you could
follow and all of these conceptions all
of these realities emotional state
cognition orientation action all of
these are involved in what goes into a
passion so you want to keep that in the
back of your mind as you're reading this
work and thinking about what Kierkegaard
is actually saying here
another thing that's quite important
that he brings up at the very end in the
epilogue he tells us the essentially
human is passion now that's something
worth dwelling on for a moment because
what have philosophers said the
essentially human is in the past reason
but just as essentially human is the
fact that we feel and what it is that we
feel towards and the fact that our
feelings can be very low ones that we
share with animals and the most sublime
so why does he tell us this the sentence
continues in which one generation
perfectly understands another and
understands itself for example no
generation has learned to love from
another no generation is able to begin
at any other point than the beginning no
later generation has a more bridge task
and if someone desires to go further and
not stop with loving as the previous
generation did then this is foolish and
idle talk we can in fact relate to
people in previous generations in
generations to come
in other cultures in you know the the
distant past on the basis of our
passions it's not perfect there's no
coincidence as a matter of fact we often
misunderstand each other while we're
feeling our emotions and relation
to each other this is where many
disputes and fights and long simmering
conflicts come from when people think
the other person or feel the other
person is feeling something that perhaps
they're not or they're not entirely or
not for the same reason and then they
respond on that basis and the other
person of course because they're not
entirely passive is doing something
similar in response and you can mix
other people into this as well and
cultural assumptions and we could go on
and on but emotion does offer us or
passion does offer us a way in which we
can bridge those gaps and come to
understand each other
he goes on and tells us that the highest
passion in a person is faith and no
generation begins at any point then
where the previous generation did
earlier on he talks about the
dialectical struggles of faith and it's
gigantic passion so he is progressively
moving from a gigantic passion early on
in the work to one of the higher
passions to the highest passion let's
talk now about the distinction that he's
making here so he tells us that faith is
no aesthetic emotion what would be an
aesthetic emotion something that is just
responding to the world that we exist in
we as you know statics is about
sensation so if I feel a certain desire
to have coffee and then I feel pleasure
in drinking the coffee or annoyance
because it's gotten cold and the milk is
congealed or any other thing like that
that would be an aesthetic emotion he
tells us faith is no aesthetic emotion
but something far higher says it's not
the spontaneous inclination of the
hearts not an automatic response but the
paradox of existence so in faith in this
emotion in this passion we wind up
relating ourselves to something that is
fundamental the paradox of existence
though the way in which we experience
things as beings who go beyond the
merely aesthetic our environments and
participate in something of the eternal
the infinite and then compare that back
to the world that we live in often
saying in the process what the hell now
a little bit later than that Kierkegaard
says that what the night of faith the
person who is living this out does is to
exist in such a way that my contrast to
existence constantly expresses itself as
the most beautiful and secure harmony
with it
that's a cognitive way of expressing
what it is that faith feels or faith
drives us towards as a passion it
requires as Kierkegaard tells us in
order for this to be the case a movement
antecedent to it of infinite resignation
which is a movement of both the will but
also of the passions so there is a
previous passional commitment of
infinite resignation that takes place
prior to faith and this can happen in
many different ways he tells us that for
example for Socrates his confession of
ignorance was his Infinite resignation
for other people it will be other things
in Abraham's case we have to imagine
that the infinite resignation was of
trying to make sense of what God was
commanding him to do and saying this
doesn't really make sense but all I
guess I have to go along with it and
then he goes beyond that into faith and
a little bit later Kierkegaard tells us
again by contrast that faith is not
within the commonplace company of
feelings moods idiosyncrasies vapors if
that was the case then full in the in
philosophy is right in saying that we
should stop with faith instead think of
it as
a passion that precisely because it is
the highest passion and does have to do
with all of existence including my own
place in it and my relation to whatever
it is that transcends or exceeds me goes
far beyond the realm of lower emotions
but could transform and incorporate them
this is where we need to talk about
something else what other passions or
emotional states or affective responses
are involved with faith there's three
that Kierkegaard constantly comes back
to in this work and you should see them
not at just as something distinct from
faith but something that faith as the
emotion that he's talking about
incorporates and that might throw you
for a bit of a loop in saying well wait
a second one emotion or passion cannot
incorporate another emotion or passion
and I'll give you a great counter
example think about anger right
Aristotle tells us that that anger
includes pain which is an emotion pain
or sorrow at being hurt insulted
something like that it also includes a
desire desire for retribution or setting
things right it also includes hope which
is the pleasant aspect to anger the hope
of being able to impose that so if anger
which is a lower emotion can be complex
enough to incorporate other emotional
states within it why could not faith
faith does for Kierkegaard it includes
anxiety and this is where you can see
that for for Kierkegaard faith is
something very very different than just
turning your brain off and believing
blindly in something it incorporates
anxiety about the very object that one
is having faith in that there will be a
good resolution that God will fulfill
his promises whatever it happens to be
love is another key emotion involved in
there as well and then he talks over and
over again about a kind of courage that
the night of faith is
able to have which he himself as the
author confesses himself unable to
exhibit although he can certainly
understand it and admire it what about
other things that he talks about that
faith is not going to be connected with
he talks about irony and humor at one
point and says that these are also
passions passions that characterized his
own age but they are reflective passions
they are passions that fall within the
realm of infinite resignation not within
faith so the person who has faith who is
exhibiting faith is not being ironic is
is not you know just engaging in humor
not to say that they couldn't also do
that but that's not integral to faith
pain when you go through the infinite
resignation there is a pain or sorrow or
sadness involved in it but for faith
instead we're going to see joy as being
the counterpart to that finally
Kierkegaard also talks about the horror
of existence that people can feel he is
not somebody who has a you know sort of
Pollyannish view on the nature of the
world it is a tough place to live and
it's not fair and many things go wrong
and there aren't rational explanations
for why things are the way that they are
that truly satisfy us and so one can
have this sort of horror that he talks
about that's not going to be part of
faith but he does talk about it in here
as well as other emotions as well so
hopefully now when you return to this
work it makes a bit more sense all these
references to faith as a passion all of
these ideas are rolled into that you
have to understand it not just as a mere
basic emotional response but as the
highest possible emotion or passion for
a person motivating their entire being
incorporating so much else making some
sort of sense out of themselves the
universe and their relation to the
divine
you